(music playing)
No matter how aggressively you optimized
your networking code for performance,
there's still a huge problematic perf issue
that you haven't seen: bloated asset files.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And if you're not aggressively attacking
the size of the assets
that you're transferring to your users,
you're basically stealing
time and money from them.
See, sending bloated assets to your users
has three big problems.
Now, number one is network speeds.
Bandwidth is still a really big problem
for most of the people around the world.
Not everyone is on 4G.
And the slower the network,
the longer it takes to download the data.
Which directly translates
to number two, battery drain.
The longer the cellular radio
is talking to the network,
the more battery it'll drain to do so.
So bloated files burn more battery.
And let's not forget number three, cost.
A majority of folks out there
aren't on unlimited data plans,
which means that every bit
they're transferring to their device
from your application costs them money,
which, if you ask me, is a raw deal
for a free application.
And unless you've taken
a hard, grinding look
at the size of the assets
that you're sending to your users,
they're going to be larger
than they need to be.
And the two biggest candidates
that cause the most bloat?
Images and serialized data.
For images, sometimes the easiest solution
is to just change what
file type you're using.
I mean, if you don't need transparency,
avoid using PNG files
because they don't compress as well as JPEG
and WEBP counterparts.
And if you are using JPEG or WEBP,
remember that small changes in quality
can have huge changes in file size.
You can crank down the quality settings
of an image a significant amount
before users start to notice any issues.
So aggressively finding
the right trade off
between quality and
size can be a huge win.
And this goes doubles for
different types of images.
Thumbnails occupy
much smaller portions of the screen.
and, thus, it's harder to
notice visual issues there.
You can get by with a much
lower quality than, say,
a full screen version where
it's easier to see compression artifacts.
And resolution is especially
important for screen sizes and needs.
There's really no reason to
send a four-megapixel image
down to a device
and only have it used as a thumbnail.
Or smaller screen devices
that can't possibly display it
at that resolution, which is why
you should store different qualities
and resolutions of the
same image on your server.
So, you can optimize for
the smallest possible file
to be sent to the users.
And if this sounds like a
''too much overhead'' for you,
remember users are paying
to download your bloated files.
So shame on you.
Now, just as problematic as images
is serialized data.
JSON and XML are horrible types
when it comes to compressed size.
I mean, they are super, super bloated.
Look at all this extra stuff
that's jammed into these files
just to make them more readable for humans
commas, spaces, quotes, carriage return.
Listen, your users don't need to pay
to send that data to their device.
Instead, you should be leveraging
binary serialization formats.
Proto buffs, nano buffs, and flat buffers
are all accessible on Android
and can reduce your data footprint
significantly with their own
nuanced implementation trade offs.
Oh, and by the way, remember
that any of the data you serialize
is going to be GZIP compressed
by the HTTP stack,
meaning that you should be adopting
a Struct-of-Arrays format to help bundle
similar typed fields together
so that the LZ stage
of the GZIP compressor
can do a better job of
finding symbol matches.
If you're confused about the size
of the assets that you're sending around
and what it's costing your users,
check out the networking and monitor tool
inside of Android Studio or the ARO tool
from AT&T. Both provide great information
that lets you track issues down.
And tracking down performance problems
is what we are all about,
which is why you need to check out
the rest of the
Android Performance Patterns content.
And also join our community on
Google+ for great advice
from people who've already solved
these problems.
So keep calm.
Profile your code.
And always remember... Perf Matters.
(music playing)